das Warten ist endlich vorbei Stadion
voller Menschen haben sehnlichst auf
diesem Moment gewartet und wirklich
niemand hätte mit diesem come back des
Jahres gerechnet nach 4 Jahren Abstinenz
ist es nämlich endlich mal wieder soweit
Luca spielt das neue FIFA 23 willkommen
zu FIFA 23 Amateur die Einstellung
ändern war dann erstmal so Legende denn
ich bin auch eine Legenden FIFA
Fußballverein 1 fC Köln du musst bei
Playstation auf verdammt habe ich wieder
die Rechnung nicht gezeigt
der spielt nicht beim FC Köln
besser ist es dass er abbaut wir spielen
heute Köln gegen Gladbach Rheinderby
junge adamian und Tickets im Sturm
Tickets ganz liebe Grüße ich habe
gesehen Erfolg bei Instagram
in Sturm kommt der kommt nee Timon kommt
auf die recht oder
oha
als wenn die solche Szenen vorher zeigen
1 fC Köln gegen Borussia Mönchengladbach
oha ja da kann man auch echt mal
klatschen dicker
sogar mit der Bundesliga
[Applaus]
in die Steuerung reinkriegen es ist
tatsächlich mein allererstes mal FIFA 23
deswegen ich weiß nicht was hier los ist
die Anzeige oben ist auf jeden Fall
anders geworden
und der Computer hatte noch einmal den
Ball
direkt beibehalten also wir spielen auf
Schwierigkeitsgrade Legende offline weil
ich kein PS Plus gekauft habe von daher
spielen wir gegen den Computer nicht
online gegen irgendwen anders ich bin oh
mein Gott ich habe den Ball verloren
das
Geld ist gut das war nicht so gut
also ich hätte wirklich ein bisschen
mehr erwartet auf Legende die wenigsten
wissen ja tatsächlich
Ecke junge keins besser raus bin ich
erklärt ich bin seit FIFA 07 bin ich
dabei hier ein Bild das bin ich und da
ist FIFA 07 da waren die meisten von
euch immer verloren er geboren
zack jetzt kommt die Ecke oh das war
knapp das war die erste große Torchance
für den ersten Fußballclub Köln
hallihall
Fußballclub Köln ja du bist mein Freund
ist es immer sein erster Fußballclub
[Applaus]
ich bin im Angriff und werde jetzt
jegliche
Frage okay wow ich hätte nicht gedacht
dass mich das so ketch aber ich spiele
halt wirklich auf der höchsten Stufe
Legende damit das mal klar als geht das
hier noch ja so sehr gut ich kann ja
fast keine Tricks mehr ne bin zwar schon
lange dabei bei Fifa aber ich habe die
letzten zwei drei Jahre wirklich nahezu
gar nicht gespielt was denn los junge
Mann egal
machen wir jetzt mal einen Lupfer hier
rein in Strafraum
okay egal zur Ruhe zu kommen zack zack
Trab Trapp
sein
da kommt der Luftfahrt
Tor für die Gäste das ist ganz klares
Abseits wir wurden jetzt zwar betrogen
erstmal alle Köln Fans kennen das aus
den vergangenen Saisons irgendwie ist es
dieses Jahr zum ersten Mal so dass der
Video ist es auch das ein oder andere
mal auf unserer Seite steht Mann was
soll das wieso verliert
boah ey muss nicht sein muss nicht sein
so ab in zwei Kampf ab wir letzten zwei
Kampf ihr tut so ein Spiel hier da
könnte man stehen
Jungs macht man den Ball da weg
was soll denn das
schon
so jetzt haben
und jetzt aber langsam
egal was auch passiert die rote man
steht an dir weil ich nicht von deiner
Seite denn los würde ich es dir
jetzt können wir es
machen soll ich mit Ansage ich brauche
jetzt keinmal mehr hat Gladbach den Ball
und ich schieße das eins eins mach
timelapse im Schnitt was war das
[Musik]
gut dazwischen gegangen
aber egal
Jungs
gefährlicher werden sonst wird es schwer
den Sieg sein
zack mitlaufen weiter geht's sehr gut
gespielt
ich bin gerade mit meiner Ferse
umgeknickt auf dem
Stuhl von meinem Schreibtisch wo die
Rollen dran sind hey es tut höllisch weh
aber es hindert mich nicht daran das
reinläufig gegen verfickt aber Borussia
Scheiß kackbacht zu gewinnen jetzt
geht's los
Halbzeit die wollt ihr mich verarschen
genau in dem Moment wo meine Motivation
wir stellen unsere Taktik um auf
offensiv ich sag's euch jetzt geht's ab
sehr gut oh wieder verloren egal wo man
zurück Jungs nochmal zurück
[Applaus]
wir konzentrieren uns allerdings meine
Damen und Herren das 2:0 macht gar
nichts an unserer Moral wir wollen immer
noch den wir haben schon wieder wir
haben ihn doch verloren vielleicht
müssen wir von offensiv auf sehr
offensiv gehen wir müssen einfach
konzentriert vorgehen die spielen aber
auch echt nicht schlecht das muss man
lassen
was für einfach Frank Buschmann was für
einfach junge wollt ihr noch näher an
seinem Mund dran suchen was übertreibt
ihr denn hier eigentlich so
Telefon
ja vielleicht auch Mailand Tennis
eine Woche Samstag
[Applaus]
hat es in sich wieder zurück oh mein
Gott ich sagte der 1 fC Köln und
offensiver Fußball das passt einfach
zusammen
passt eine Faust eigentlich aufs Auge
das stimmt gar nicht
soll ich denn jetzt gemacht was war das
was habe ich gerade getan
und was warum
wartet mal ganz kurz was habe ich gerade
gemacht ich wollte gerade Test ob die
Faust aufs Auge passt aber das passt
nicht aber warum ist jetzt warum war das
was
gibt eine Anzeige die Chance
was macht der denn was macht der denn 20
einfach wirklich beste Spiel was ich je
gespielt habe macht ultra Spaß gar keine
Bugs drin erst zu Beginn
den halte ich diesmal
will ja wie so ein Trottel in die Mitte
schießen ich habe einfach nur vergessen
mich zu bewegen bin ich ganz ehrlich
aber egal ab geht's
los
fängt diesen Ball an meinen Arsch und
zack auf die Außen mal rüber keins in
die Mitte ziehen oh mann ey es ist doch
einfach wirklich zum Mäuse melken tolles
Liebling da sind sie alle machtlos da
hat er die Chance drin ist der Ball
alles offen also so einfach dürfte sie
natürlich nicht machen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich deinstalliere die